je suis excusé excusez moi de vous
déranger au milieu des applaudissements
je m'excuse mais excusez moi de vous
déranger mais voilà j'ai j'ai eu une
démarche très difficile à faire je
voudrais vous demander une aide ou un
secours ou les deux à la fois si
possible ou bien dans une espèce qui
serait le mieux bien sûr les espèces
aériennes que les espèces alors si vous
voulez enfin monsieur vous voyez bien
que je suis gêné là vous êtes gênés et
bien pas tant que moi même si vous savez
comme oxygène et moi vous savez vous
savez je ne refuse jamais d'aider les
gens quand je peux oui mais je voudrais
bien savoir à quel titre
d'autant plus que je n'ai pas l'honneur
de vous connaître et oui mais je suis
alors je suis gêné c'est pour ça que je
suis gêné alors expliquez moi mais je
vais vous expliquer voilà monsieur voilà
monsieur monsieur je suis un artiste
sans prétention jeu et sont contents
ronald je peux vous dire que je suis un
très grand musicien un très grand bien
mais je n'ai pas de chance je n'ai pas
de chance tout ce que j'entreprends dans
la vie dans l'art dans la musique ne me
réussit jamais j'ai pas de chance je
suis dit nuc ont pas un pur hasard comme
cathy scoumoune a comme régiment de
malchance oh là là là ça fait beaucoup
pour un seul homme
et oui ça fait beaucoup de bouches à
nourrir surtout un alors rocade alors
voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai pas de
chance je voudrais que vous me donniez
si vous aussi vous m'aidiez et pourtant
je suis musicien je voudrais que vous
m'aidiez par un petit chèque non barré
c'est possible ou alors ou alors des
billets de 10 ou de 50 mais des 56
lemieux qui a si vous avez de 50 ya pas
mieux que ça attendez attendez attendez
vous avez de 50
non non c'est trop mesquin la ville
bâtie en on m'avait dit vous étiez
musiciens oui monsieur mais bien ça ça
m'intéresse mais j'ai pas de chance
monsieur rien ne me réussi dans la vie
j'ai confiance ça me réussit pas
monsieur je vous assure ça me réussit
écoutez ne vous découragez pas à laisser
moi mais comment vous êtes musicien mais
de quels instruments jouets vous de quel
instrument je joue oui mais enfin vous
jouer peut-être du piano de la guitare
de la batterie
non non moi je joue pas le jeu moi je
joue j'ai joutes la viole de gambe la
cua dai young en bas âge la viole de
gambe est très bien attendez moi un
instant je reviens sur si vous avez de
50 c'est mieux ou en espèces
parce que de 50 voilà monsieur est ce
que vous pouvez pas me jouer un petit
morceau en attendant un petit cercle et
de derrière les fagots dans leur merci
ça j'ai pas besoin
voyez monsieur la green congé vous voyez
la poisse que j'ai monsieur je vous ai
dit que j'étais digne e v remous sociaux
je vous ai dit que je jouais de laguiole
de gambe et vous a réussi à trouver le
vieux daugan panier et ses enfants
réfugiés quelque chose qui nous la voir
ma tristesse et demi les patineurs où il
y avait dedans mais l'on m'avait donné
un télégramme pour vous j'ai oublié dans
mes occupations j'avais pas que ça
passait par la junte et les grands pour
vous tenez prenez le pis c'est tout mais
ne partez pas peut-être que j'ai un
mandat on sait jamais mais miracle grâce
à dieu oulala c'est encore mieux
commandes à deux mandats
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle à vous
annoncer d'ailleurs j'ai vous lire le
texte oui arrive et d'argentine
stop grande vedette internationale stop
susanna raynaldy top weight est prête à
chanter
stop elle attend en coulisses alors il
faut que les châtelains plastoc
oui mais ça c'était pas dans le
télégramme mettons partir quand même